hey guys it's Justine I'm so excited
because today I'm joined with Josh now
this is really exciting because some of
you guys might know that I like to
juggle but you can do it really I I can
juggle I've been known to juggle you
also have a bunch of Guinness World
Record I do I'm 12 wait 12 wow I've got
the world record for most samurai swords
juggled most apples sliced while
juggling longest time to juggle five
basketballs most toilet paper rolls
balanced on your head most marshmallows
caught in your mouth in 30 seconds if
there's a few okay I'm gonna list the
rest of them right here I'm extremely
impressed I haven't done anything yet so
I'm winning so far that's Twitter and
YouTube and this is so cool so today we
don't really know what we're gonna do
but you brought a bunch of stuff but you
also said that you wanted to try
something I did about these balls that
you played on fire and Jenna my sister
told me that I probably shouldn't try
them because I'm gonna get hurt but
that's why that's why you brought me I
was like this yard in half so it's okay
and I brought you uh I brought you a
little present
Josh Horton juggling balls Wow Wow okay
son let's see okay no pressure
there's a lot of I'm just a gold
medalist juggler okay so I'm kind of
basic no looks great I can do one of
these because I love that I like the
like cycle I roll low like that and
that's it like this and I'm good I can
do like one of those and then I started
with four but I'm not like that good at
it oh oh wait you can do it okay that
was great yeah so four is two in your
right hand plus 2nu your left hand just
like that yeah you juggle three and I'm
gonna steal them and then you'll steal
them back
I don't have other than that I know yeah
okay now you see I'll take that one
first it's got a commit so dude dude
dude dude dude okay this is a little
more tricky something like that yeah
Cole's gonna give you those I'm not
gonna juggling us I don't want them to
get punished if I drop them you guys
[Music]
of this there there oh wow wow wow
one of the world records that have is
most apples sliced while juggling knives
in 30 seconds and so just a nice
underhand toss from you I'll be juggling
knives and then I'll slice the Apple
hold on I move maybe step back just a
little bit just no no you're good you're
good you're good
are you okay hold on three two one did I
get it let's try again one two okay
let's try it one more time okay got it
this is so cool sliced it nice let's do
one more time this is really fun take it
make it a little bit higher yeah oh shut
up now oh my gosh you're eating the
Apple and juggling knives yeah yeah so
how long have you even know English
i started in second grade that's cool
yeah like a cert PE class basically yeah
my Boston teacher and she started seeing
her kids to juggle and she was just
learning and she bought me some scarves
and this is really fun yeah wow wow this
is so great I bought some clothes can
you kidding myself you can't do clothes
Wow
[Music]
so are there any records that you're
currently trying to beat right now or
should you not tell anyone because then
they'll try to beat you I'm like always
well on my youtube channel I break a
world record every Wednesday yeah so we
do world record Wednesdays it's not all
it's not all juggling yeah I'm always
looking for the next next world record
and I've definitely tried it before
little let's go see your first flip one
two three yeah yeah Wow
are you left-handed or right-handed oh I
can do seven of these seven start
juggling and kick it forward and then
continue chuckling Wow insert GarageBand
children too
[Applause]
but we haven't kind of thing on fire we
promised that beginning this video there
will be we see we briefly read the
directions I bought these a while ago
and I didn't attempt to use them because
I a little bit scared so right now we're
wetting the outer little rim here that's
supposed to like help protect your hands
yeah and like you can even with easy you
can hold them like that and it's not
gonna burn you because the flame isn't
right in the middle this part doesn't
catch on fire I'm gonna go on tour with
my one trick you'll get a little bit of
fuel on the wicks so it's gonna show you
do this yeah the flaming bucket
this is what we uh you know put things
in when we flame through all right
that's it please no I don't really know
should we just see if one works first I
guess I just jam it in there yeah yeah
that's working oh jeez oh gosh I'm
scared I'm scared Ringo do you think I
will I think you'll be alright okay I'll
just enjoy seeing I might it don't know
it just it does get actually kind of hot
sometimes no make sure are you okay
there we go
so Jay you know I don't get it kind of
hot I remember I used to have these and
I flick oh these are rubber things were
getting hot are they supposed to come
off I don't know we didn't read the
directions so I read the end of it if
you're struggling then you're probably
doing it wrong I think we did it right
okay as long as you keep moving it's fun
different they'll hold on to a very long
time hey hey Gary yes Ian yeah I'm good
look good all right yep just okay just
throw it up shoot I mean I don't swear
my channel I mean look I'm flicker flame
okay okay so I guess just throw it up
[Laughter]
okay yes
I'm panicking I'm panicking so this is
all training for for this moment right
now yep there you go all right it's
getting warm
oh my gosh you're so calm
you're so calm I'm you do not well
you'll see you might oh gosh wow this is
cool I'm super impressed oh my goodness
hello Chris my ponytail is right off how
are they feeling good it feels a lot
better actually here are you digging
back okay yeah
nice you good yeah I'm good I'm just
trying to turn around quicker
oh god that one burned a little bit I'm
gonna have fairly decent health
insurance
JD hey it's doing back yep I'm glad I
taught you the steel this is the best
way to get in here yeah without you
panicking steel with that one hand
nice the flames are getting smaller oh
geez why I said you did a good job
you're right I'm good and it just uh it
was a lot of things
oh yeah you're so calm I have done it
for oh yeah that's right I've got one
last thing to catch on fire yeah yeah
yes oh it's like a dark now look great
okay so I'm gonna juggle one of these
one of these is a whoa little katana the
flaming battle axe destiny
so this catches on fire so much maybe I
should have said I'm gonna drill all
four of these I'm gonna try you can do
whatever you want you get back out now
I'm juggling okay with that that's okay
so that's whoa whoa whoa should I go
away where do I go I'm a neither thing
okay oh my gosh I am so impressed
[Laughter]
poor things with this before so we go
what else you know thumbnail oh yeah
don't hold any of this stuff okay great
thumbnail taken um Wow
there we go maybe next time I will have
a new trick to show you that would be
awesome see I'll work on what should I
work on with my homework I like to see
you get that like a solid four ball
jungle okay you just like throws that
was good thank you
done more before but I'm having an off
day no problem well guys thank you so
much for watching and Josh thank you so
much for coming over
thank you me some juggling trick you bet
and you name burn my house down I did
not I mean the fact that I haven't
burned my house down that's saying
something
sure you go check out josh's channel
youtube uh Twitter Instagram Facebook
I'll put all of the links below and be
sure to go subscribe to the YouTube
channel
thank you so much thank you so great
we're gonna go to the grocery store and
juggle some things now yeah that'll be
on my channel let's go let's go grocery
shopping let's do it okay
[Music]
yes yes you clean
the crowd goes wild
[Music]